very very easy to talk to you could open
up to him
and just just having that person in my
life you know that knows
me and better than anyone else camille's
dad
paul hildich died two days after
christmas
active and always on the go he was a
teacher
in the north east a job he loved when
you have a teacher who really is
passionate about their subjects it
really
you know engages you as a person and i
generally think when he was in school
that's how he came across he always used
to come in and say things like our best
lesson ever today
and he actually you know inspired a lot
of people to go to university
camille lived with her dad they both
caught covered at the start of december
but while she recovered paul got worse
complete shock we're still still in
shock really all our family because
even in the darkest hours of his
treatment it's something you never
expected would happen
to such a healthy fit person only only
55
was only a month before climbing
scaffold pike
you know the highest mount in england
paul was
happiest outdoors but his family say
when teachers are in the classroom
they need better protection i think
teachers should definitely be getting
priority for the vaccinations right now
and if they're going to send them into
schools you know they need to be
vaccinated
personally i think they shouldn't be
back until they are vaccinated
there'll be an empty seat at future
family celebrations
and a heartbreaking gap in the life of
those left behind
my sister's getting married um next year
and you know she's already said you know
who's gonna walk me down the aisle now
um and it's just one of those things i
think
um it will go on forever this i think
the grieving one
you know when you go for these life big
big moments in life
and he's not there and he'll really hit
home you know that he's not there
anymore
laura bundock sky news durham